okay for people joining this
live stream we are looking at
incremental language development for
language and we have a variety of
topics for today i'm hoping we're going
to get through these early topics
quite quickly and then we'll be on to
pretty meaty stuff here
but let's take a look okay
so the question is what does the order
function do
and should we have other ones so we also
have
i mean right now we have numeric sort
don't we
numerical sort an alphabetic sort
okay and um the issue here is that we
don't have genuine lexicographic
sort exactly because our default order
uh choose its length before looking at
the first
element right
so the the way one will get
lexicographic sorting would be
i mean the question is whether we should
provide lexicographic sort
or whether we just want
a lexus graphic order function you would
give us a second argument to sort
right so the precedent we have with our
other
order functions is that we have both we
have
numerical order and numerical sort and
alphabetic order and alphabetical sort
a little bit overkill but it's probably
not harmful right
i mean lexicographic order
so alphabetics order
so alphabetic is about the languages and
writing scripts
and i see it it depends
on the actual writing system and so on
and it can sort even with
yeah right i understand where does the
acute go and things
right and we have examples of like
depending on the language
right the right the ch might be ordered
differently depending on the language
right okay but so alexa the point is
right now sort and order um
you know are for dealing with
expressions and they
but but for strings what do they do
right now what does sort do for strings
um it uses the canonical order which is
based on our unicode tables i mean it's
not
no i didn't i didn't mean i i meant the
question of whether it sorts
by first by length and then by content
or does it
probably by length i i think it would be
consistent with
yeah okay so for example okay so so it
is therefore treating
the non-existence of a character as
being
before everything else correct
the end of string is effectively um
appears in the sorting order before
every character
effectively yes okay
but so the different case would be
where's the case where lexicographic
sort for strings will be different from
current sort for strings
well but lexicographic here is for
non-atomic expressions so the important
thing is when we have two expressions of
the same head
do we look first at the length or at the
first element
and we don't have a way of providing
order by
first element first
right i understand i understand but i
mean
for the combinator project we enumerated
many different kinds of orderings
right which i think are in the um did
you make a link to those here
uh no but we actually were looking at
one of your
uh blogs and that's gonna take evolving
right we forgot to other i think here
okay fine but i mean so so
um well let's let's look at this for a
second i mean because this is
this came up um
let's take a look here it's a
ridiculously long vlog
ah must be somewhere around here i mean
i enumerated a bunch of these orders
which are not
by no means exhaustive right because
there's
all possible you know the question is
what is a what is a short to describe
order
right i mean orders in principles there
could be
all permutations of a given list
right exactly so so here here's the
table
right of of different kinds of orderings
right
so i was just checking right now and our
sorting of strings is actually
lexicographic in the sense that if we
sort
string b and string a a it's going to
place
first a a even though it's longer than b
okay well that's not bad i mean it's
kind of crazy i
i seem to remember at one point many
many many years ago i mean my
my memory for time maybe maybe off here
but like 25 years ago some some glitch
with that
um okay but so in these cases here that
we
we've got enumerated here right
i'm a little bit confused by so
for example these cases in which you
have the um
let's see the the first two lines those
are lexicographic in the sense that
they will put first things starting with
zero
irrespectively of the length
right if we had the linguists of
integers
we could not do that easily
right i don't actually now understand
the difference between these um
gosh it's only a few weeks since i wrote
this this is terrible
um oh i see that they're simply sorting
in in the opposite order
depending on which which one
they're effectively sorting by length
reversed by length
right so i think half of these is
is just reversed order the ones that
start with one
and then you have lexicographic versus
right right most is just starting with
one that's that's trivial
so the ones of interest are the leftmost
and then the
so and then the question is are you
going length you know from longest to
shortest
shortest to longest or are you just
doing it lexicographically independent
of length
correct
now the fact is you know it's not like
we've needed these exotic sorting orders
most of the time so
i mean i do think this lexicographic
case i can imagine
you know that being useful um all right
what is the issue here it has been so so
the thing is that lexicographic order
needs to specify the actual order
that will be used to sort the elements
so that's why it needs a parameter
and and in that sense it's similar to
alphabetical order that requires the
specification of a language
that is more why does this i see so in
other words it needs
it is comparing this thing to this thing
this thing to this thing
but it also could have a different
default for if there isn't an element
there right
it's beginning at the beginning but the
question is if one of them runs out of
steam
what does it do well the shorter one is
always first that's the whole point of
lexicographic right
okay the shortest one after all the
previous elements are identical
yes because because the empty
expression let's say goes before
anything else
okay okay but
but this is if the expressions have the
same head now the question is what
happens if the expressions have
different
head how do we sort the heads and what
i'm suggesting here is that we use order
and not the capital order and not the
order that the user provided
because for example if we have elements
that are numeric or strings
we don't want to sort the heads by
numeric order or
alphabetical order
i'm sorry except uh right numeric order
alphabetical order defi
default to order for things which are
you know not one of those things so is
it really
not really for example alphabetical
order if it doesn't find
strings complaints oh i didn't i don't
i mean numerical order is certainly
documented and i believe it does default
to order for things which are not
numeric
yes but that may be something that the
users do not
expect or do not have to rely on
well i think yeah okay i'm sorry so
you're saying for the comparison of the
e sub i to the g
sub i is that right yes that's why it
has the p
you see lexicographic hp
yes okay that p is the ordering function
deciding how to order the
e i e i but you were making some comment
about heads but you're not talking about
the heads h
you're talking about the heads imagine
that the next case in which we have h1
h2 we still have to sort that so how do
we decide
which head comes first h1 or h2
i understand do we just order are you
saying alphabetic
sort only works on strings currently
that's the case
okay so what about alphabetical order
i think we complain that i'm not getting
strings
are you sure let me check
yes it does oh it does
okay which numeric order does not do
and would it make sense to lexicographic
orders to refuse to do it if the heads
are different
yeah i mean it's really a case that i
mean it is an error right i mean
it should complain okay
so like alphabetical go ahead
and i i was going to say that we have
both precedents in the two cases we have
alphabetical order and numeric order
numerical order
so
not the best situation but i mean i'm
sure we thought about it for those
um look the safest thing to do is to
have it just
return unevaluated for the case where
the heads are different
um and i tend to think lexicographic
sort like psychographic order
they seem both worth having and
that final sorting function seems
necessary i mean that final
sort function seems necessary right
i think it is right now in both
sort and
in both sort and ordered queue returning
unevaluated is effectively
treated as being an order i mean if it
issues a message you'll see the message
but
sorry you're saying for the sort case
if you're saying if i say alphabetic
sort in this case no
i'm saying if you do if you do sort
of alphabetic order oh i see
yeah i understand the different
different things sort here
i see sort has a certain default
i see you're saying that what does sort
do if it doesn't have minus one or plus
one or whatever
it treats it as being in order okay
yeah so effectively plus one
which you know for the case of say less
right if less can't decide if these are
you know sensible it's sensible
in this case it might be less sensible
it gave a message
what kind what else can we do well
alphabetic order gave a message
but yes
right okay well okay are we happy with
this lexicographic order
and lexicographic sort makes sense
and what lexica and would lexicographic
order of bracket bracket
be you know
the order equivalent to lexicographic
order of order or will
users have to write that out no no why
yes so if you don't specify the third
argument
by default this order like we always
default to
everyone right an operator form
too like alphabetical
which is the one argument alphabetic
form which which is which takes the
third argument
as its operative form exactly
makes sense to me okay okay
good right that's cool
yeah okay
okay all right let's go on to the echo
family
right i am keen on this one this
echo temporary thing seems really quite
useful to me
in other words you're um
you're basically you know it's it's a
way of generating
you know messages from something without
leaving detritus in the notebook
right well the question is should it
have
print temporary styling or echo styling
can we compromise what is the print
temporary styling
right it's sort of the bluish progress
bar
no i don't think it's like a print
i don't think so
it doesn't show oh i thought okay i
thought it had the blue styling maybe
i'm
confusing it with something else you
have to say print temporary of panel
with the specifications blue
specifications by the way in twelve two
how much
of the new monitoring framework got
deployed
what new monitoring framework the
progress
bar framework um
not as much as we would like who is
project managing that
we are yeah so devon can you comment on
what got deployed what didn't and why
well it just wasn't i mean the the fro
most of the work was on framework level
stuff and it
wasn't really
so the things that we directly updated
were updated um but
things that required you know other
people to hook things up
weren't hooked up because it wasn't
ready in time for it to propagate out
okay but so now that framework is ready
so now
for the next development cycle and for
anything that's packed updated we are in
a position to
add it yes i think so
devin do you have a list of targets uh
yeah we have a big list of all the
functions that could
end up taking the new framework
so i think it's your thing to go chase
those people
and try and get it installed yeah sense
is there any meeting where we can get a
status report on that
maybe maybe user assistance will be the
right place to get a status
it's not that's not the right set of
people i mean
i mean it's me and and julia who are who
are the leads
okay so i mean john and and those folk
they we they consult for us obviously
because we need front-end
things but all right so that may be
it's it's it's an lc it's an lcc topic
so
we can add to the next lcc agenda fine
let's do it
okay here's my concern about the echo
temporary
i'm concerned that we're going to want
everything echoey temporary
everything that is an echo to have a
temporary form
because i think it's going to be very
useful and the question is is there a
different
way of doing something where you can say
something like
you know temporarily temporary
the fact that i can't spell this is a
bad sign temple rare
ah for gonna say okay temporarily echo
of expert or something like that
go ahead what would echo temporary
actually do
i mean it cannot display anything until
its argument has finished evaluating
and then it will just sit there until
everything else is evaluated yeah until
the main loop until it returns to the
top level
so so what so what's the point then if
there's a second echo temporary does it
replace the first one or does it add to
it or
it adds to it kind of
i mean i think i think i think an echo
temporary is not
i think that's easy
um right good the right the emp
the print temporary doesn't end when it
finishes
isn't deleted when it finishes
evaluating right it
right yes it's deleted when when the
whole evaluation is
over print tempo is usually used with
dynamic
but echo temporary is supposed to
return what do you mean no it's not
print temporary is just something that
you can put into your code
that will not leave detritus after it
hits the main loop again
right that's its point i mean the point
of echo temporary would be
i've got tons of debugging information
that i'm going to give
but i just don't want to see it once the
function is finished
and i don't want to have to remove it
because right now a lot of times
i'm removing you know echoes because i
just don't want it's so annoying that
the the thing is littering up my
notebook even though i actually don't
want to
you know get what i'm saying but
yeah i mean the normal echo brings these
extra cells that stay around right and
so echo temporary would
just remove those cells once it's done
that's the whole difference yeah exactly
what once it hits the main loop
not it's done once that
when the current eighth well i'm not
actually i'm not sure if it's when the
current evaluation or when the
evaluation queue is empty
um i think it's the current evaluation i
think it's a i think it's sell by cell
basis isn't it
i think it's based on on sales let's
find out
yeah it's what well right but that but
you may hit the main loop multiple times
in a single cell if you have multiple
inputs in a single cell
okay so i don't know about that case
right
okay so people are confused i mean
still trying to think of a case where
that would actually be useful
because i mean any place you use echo
but you don't want it
to remain after you're done the cell is
done
[Music]
evaluating
yeah i mean i'm not super convinced with
the utility because usually
if i'm sticking in an echo i
want to study that and then reverse
engineer
so you know i'm there are two use cases
okay let me let me be clear
there are two use cases here for
ordinary echo
when you're doing debugging you want it
to stick around
okay so let me give you a scenario where
i would use echo temporary
i've got a big computation that i'm
running in a notebook
it's going to sit there it's going to
run for four hours okay
i want to have some idea what it's doing
but at the end of it and for example
i am perfectly have it happy to have it
scroll off the screen telling me what
it's doing
but at the end of it i just want the
result
see what i'm saying at the end i don't
need to see all that stuff that happened
in the intervening period
but i do need to see plenty of stuff to
tell me whether it's still running or
whether it crashed or whatever
else right well i guess i feel the more
natural way to do that would be print
temporary of some dynamic expression
that
you know reports reports things to you
but right because otherwise you'd need
to sprinkle
print you know for one thing i'm not
sure why you need the echo variant here
as opposed to the print but
right you'd need to echo your you know
sprinkle echoes all over the place
whereas
no no no not all over the place i mean
let me find you a real example
um i mean normally for debugging i'm
more interested in the input
of my functions than the output so
if i have a table i would like to see
what the current value value of the loop
variable is
not what the result of table of f of i
is okay i'm going to give you my
my case if i can find it
i have no idea if this is if this is a
real one but but um
i don't think this is a real one hold on
one second here
yeah this is a real one okay here we go
okay so what's happening here is
you can see i'm running some function
i've got an echo here
because i actually want the results i
don't want to have to put in a print and
this and that and a semicolon and
whatever else
okay um and i've got here i've got all
these results
but i actually don't care about the once
i've got the answer it's like i'm a
happy person if
it if it died trying so to speak then i
want to see how far it got
right but
i mean actually that's an interesting
question if i
if i press abort what will happen to all
the echo temporaries what happens to
print temporary
if i bought the expression i
don't know i would have assumed they go
away
yeah it goes away okay okay now if it
crashes
uh it won't go away yeah presumably
right now no out actually
it if i if i quit the kernel
it does go away
so i'm i'm not quite sure
maybe there's front end support so if
just the front end kernel
front end is is the thing that removes
it right
well except i would have yeah i guess it
must be setting up
some something in in the front end
that um
well okay so what you guys are claiming
what are you claiming here you're
claiming
hmm well i mean in in the case you're
showing here on the right i mean
clearly the first one that the echo of
the input
of the file name right that
can be done either way well no
it's it's right now i just have it
because the return value from export
okay so i mean this echo of now i agree
is gratuitous
that could perfectly well be a print
temporary of now
so the real question is we need a
different solution to this whole yes
maybe the maybe the issue is this is
some kind of
you know maybe it's a combinator
actually that we need because what we
need is something where
i can both echo the export and return
the export
right so this is another one of these
functions where basically what we're
saying is
we've got an expression okay
and we want to evaluate f of x bar
but return x bar yeah
but i mean on the right hand side
wouldn't you also have
a single line well isn't that a function
i mean right isn't that what echo
function does
is to do what is to evaluate a function
right but it returns x
it prints f but it returns exper
right exactly but what i'm saying is if
we could execute f of x bar
but return x per so it's basically just
this
i mean in other words it's a function
that just does this
right so then what we could do is we
could say whatever that function is you
know
let's call it side effect okay so let's
say we say side effect of
f applied to exper becomes
you know do evaluate f of x bar
and then um so then what we would do for
print temporary
is all we'd have to do is we'd say side
effect print temporary
and then that's what we would insert in
our code
what if f of x bird never evaluates
expert
i'm not concerned about that i think in
this case this
sub-value would have already evaluated
x-bar
so if f is a don't evaluate your
argument function you're out of luck
i mean honestly this clean up function
that we just or with cleanup that we
just added
is another example of a thing in this
family
i mean it has some special features
right
i mean if i say with cleanup
what that's doing it's actually
that particular one has much more
evaluation control
and with cleanup is is saying evaluate
you know it's got a net expert
it's got basically a pre and expert and
a post
right but it returns expert
see what i'm saying
and that's what's useful is being able
to do something like this
and then in principle
well i don't know what do you guys think
about this
so i tried echo function of print
temporary
and it doesn't do what i was expecting
oh it will do something completely crazy
echo function isn't the right place to
put this because echo function
is already echoing
right i mean the other possibility for
this particular functionality of
temporary
would be a wrapper around the printed
object
which means you know look for example we
could imagine a thing that says
temporary output
okay this is another interesting idea
actually i need to start saving this
file
um uh where am i saving this to
uh you've saved other similar things in
functional programming
okay
okay so this is another possible idea
but
independent of this idea which i think
is an interesting idea in its own right
okay this idea is a a thing
that when output has the feature that it
simply disappears
yeah but what does it mean when output
well i'm saying it disappears when the
when you iterate the main loop
uh let's see does this make any sense so
in other words i don't think this makes
sense
well i mean the weird case says you
could have a table
you could have three of these and they
would get left over
like the you know like that cheshire cat
idea so to speak
where only the um you know where only
the list bracket remains
um right where what does this do
when it hits the main loop so so in
other words the idea would be
i don't think we have anybody from the
front end team here but
um the idea would be this is a thing
that appears on the screen
but disappears at the end of this it's
pretty crazy
it's crazy if we get the whole cell to
disappear that would make more sense
it's amusing i mean you've got to give
it points for that
it will be very bizarre okay go ahead
what are we going to say
yes i mean looking at your example on
the right-hand side
i mean you have essentially three echoes
right
now wouldn't it be cool if if you turn
those into echo temporary
then they would overwrite the earlier
instance of
itself no it wouldn't no it would happen
you would have those three you would
have those three
lines so you would essentially have an
easy way of
of creating a point temporary of dynamic
i mean yeah but if you
you're right well i think if that's what
you wanted that you should do a print
temporary of dynamic
yes but then you have to introduce local
variables and uh
you have to modify big mess i mean it's
a big mess
temporary returns a cell object that you
could delete before you
print the next one as well these are all
messy
i mean what roman is describing is
something where
all i'm describing okay so the question
is what
uh what removes uh an echo temporary
but why cannot we consider that echo
temporary is the
type setting like echo version of print
temporary
and it follows the same rules there's no
reason we can't
except that i'm worried that we're going
to go down a slippery slope of wanting
echo evaluation well
well yes right well but let me point out
that at least at the present time your
your operatory form sub value
side effect guy can't handle the echo
evaluation
case
what right the your your headdress
version
side effect no i can't handle it i agree
that can't handle it
so what about an option that says remove
after
yes i think that's a possibility as well
but i think that that
i mean one possibility is that all of
them have the option
and echo temporary is just a convenient
thing to get an echo alone
that um
um
um the the you know that that has some
uh yeah right so i mean let's say
that it said um i don't know what they
you know let's let's say that it had an
option
do we have an option i mean that's it
temporaries and no i know what temporary
is that's
that's for variables um but uh
do we have an option that says um
generate output don't we have options
that relate to the progress monitor
that say generate this output and then
go away
no we have like weather to generate
uh right we have thought you know we
have
progress reporting which is you know
nothing
everything you know after a delay etc
and there's like a delay but we don't
have a
go away after a certain amount of time
right actually a question from our live
stream here is the progress monitoring
framework going to be documented it
really should be i mean do we have
top-level functions for doing it
sort of what are they uh well i mean we
have something that's
not in system and okay
let me know should we be promoting it to
that what is the basic structure
of that thing uh does it work with
callbacks or does it work some other way
it will well go there's a futurized
rough page for the function even though
it's not in system
which is evaluate with progress
oh very interesting
that's a cool idea for a function
well this is what we're all supposed to
use now right internally yes
okay so let's take a look at what this
is saying so
for example if i do evaluate with
progress map of such and such a thing
what will happen does it do anything
useful or not
uh well you would have to
set something up uh
how does it put hooks into expo how does
that work
well you have to put the hooks okay so
does this specify what the hooks are
uh maybe you should look at some of the
examples
um
right so you tell it watch this variable
and you know you can give an
interpretation to that variable
and that's the thing that uh how does it
get the variable wait a minute how does
it
it's specified there in the sa in in the
association you see progress
goes to i yes
so but wait a minute it's outside the do
how is it scoped correctly um
[Music]
i guess monitor manages to do it but how
does it do it
and for example with a map dynamic
what's that probably uses dynamic which
right
it picks it up automatically i mean it's
it's uh
[Music]
dynamically scoped right
okay but how would it do it for the
internal variable of a map
well it can't i mean we'd have to modify
map to to do that right and if map
if map right and they believe map you
know doesn't actually evaluate anything
right it just
applies the function and then returns it
right but map knows how far it got
through the thing it's mapping onto i
mean the case that i use
all the time whenever i use parallel of
a parallel map
i always use the resource function um
parallel map monitored
yes i mean the problem which has which
has a whole bunch of limitations
it's right it's not in any way a drop in
replacement for map
no no i i i'm aware of this however i
will tell you one thing
which is even though max believed that
its display is not that useful
i can tell you having used it for a year
the display is really useful even if
it's estimates for how long it will take
aren't always accurate
because it's it's just estimating based
on what's already happened
it's just highly highly useful
i mean yes but you know
a random wall from function repo doesn't
have to consider all the cases that
map has to no no i i agree i'm just
saying that i'm saying
that the thing we should work towards we
know this is that at least parallel map
should by default come up with a with a
monitoring thing
right and one of one of the things i
mean one of the internal quests
one of the unresolved questions in the
framework is
you know how to monitor a c-level
variable
right so so the things that have been
hooked up are all things which have at
least some portion in top level
and then you you know you're monitoring
a wolfram language variable yeah
look i think it's hopeless i think what
has to happen is
functions like map have to have an
option
that can expose their internal
you know it can that where map has some
function basically
where which it is applying well how
would you do this
right so well i mean but right but
before we
before we worry how to expose this to
the user which may or may not be a
problem in the end
the first problem we have to solve is
how can our framework
even access right because if we if we
if we do the work of making map aware
in such a way that you know thing it can
be monitored
then the user doesn't have to worry
about it right if we add a progress
monitoring
option to map itself right then the user
doesn't have to worry about it
but there's still the problem of how to
actually make that work and
is there a way to do it so that not
every single developer has to write
you know can we create a c level
framework to automate this so everybody
just needs to put in a little hook in
their c function
or does every c code developer have to
you know write a whole
yeah well i mean i think that clearly
there are some
functions like map and so on which are
clearly
uh i agree that's
that that map is highly desirable right
and and it's it's something we've
thought about it's just not something
we've solved yet
okay i mean but arguably we should try
and solve map as a special case because
we'll learn a bunch of stuff about
because a it's useful and b will learn a
bunch of stuff about what the general
framework should be
just from doing that special case then
of course the question is how do you
activate it would you have to set an
option or could you
just wrap could you just say evaluate
with progress of map
without that second argument and it
would
use its internal code how do you
activate it yeah yeah right i think it
would not be the second argument case i
think it would be
i think just like with echo it would be
you know with progress right you could
say
just like you can say echo you could say
with progress and then the
your typical code would look like you
know you previously have and
unfortunately with map you know we don't
often be things like this
f slash add x and then you would be
saying with
progress of or
or it could just have a a you know be
like others and default to
you know dollar progress right we add
the progress reporting option to map
which defaults to automatic
and yeah that's that respects that
respect
and that respects a global variable so
if you want to force it to always be on
you can set that field the other point
is go ahead
it could use echo progress
[Laughter]
what does that mean well it would
without
just like this i mean just a different
in
in the idea of having something that
doesn't modify that just modify the
semantics so we don't have to specify
options or
right i see i mean that's
that's easy as echo bogus could be
it could be block of dollar progress
monitor equals to
f at x right and then it would pick up
that option setting something like that
yes well except that what worries me
about
these things is how deep does it go
right because because i can imagine a
situation where somebody has
you know there's random internal code
that happens to be using map or
something
and it's like you start seeing you know
some complicated variable with with you
know
in some giant internal context that's
being monitored and you don't really
want that
i mean what you want is i've got this
particular function
and you know it's like you want
something where
the proximate head is being monitored
but nothing below that
if that makes sense yes i mean he could
reset the option to
to false internally or something well
but what i'm what i'm saying is that
with progress would be
more like i mean it would happen to work
nicely in this case would be more like a
headdress
for the for the head
you know
um
so for that earlier one it'd be with
progress of map
yes yes it would be
but i wonder if christopher wants to
join us here i think
she might be around maybe if um uh
um is can somebody reach out to emma and
see if she can reach christopher
um
okay but i mean i think we should be
having this discussion with
in the lcc meeting with all the relevant
people as opposed to
some side discussion about the design of
the progress monitoring no i understand
i understand i understand but this is
related to the echo temporary because
echo temporary
is being used like the progress monitor
echo temporary is a one-shot version
you know there's a special case in a
sense of a progress monitor because
that's because
it's going to go away the same way as
the progress monitor goes away
sure
but i do think
yeah i mean
see i can imagine okay here's another
question
do we want an echo temporary okay the
next question is the scoping of echo
temporary
because let's imagine that we did the
following okay
uh let's say that we had a function
called
uh you know let's imagine it was called
temporary block
a very bad name but blah blah blah blah
blah we got a bunch of echo temporaries
in here
okay and let's imagine that
temporary block removes the echo
temporaries
so in other words what i'm seeing is
i've got some piece of my code
there's a bunch of of um kind of
activity in that piece of code
then it's over then i want to see them
then those echo temporaries go away
so i'm saying and then then the only
constraint is that temporary block
in effect is the thing that is
implicitly wrapped
around every top level rebel
line
this isn't totally silly because this
way you could
have right i mean this is this is a way
of
defining what do people think of this
i think it's kind of interesting
i think my main question is why would we
need these for eco temporary
if we never felt the need in print
temporary
because i think more people will use
echo temporary than have ever used print
temporary
why what why well look at how many
people use echo
echo is very popular
and print two yeah okay
what about something in in quiet eco
like there's a quiet echo with a timing
it will wait and it removes every type
of echo
including the echo temporaries
well i mean you mean that quiet echo
could say
i mean yeah your quiet echo is a rapper
obviously
which quiets every echo inside it
and what you're saying is this
temporary block thing
it's like a quiet echo that only only
quiets it that only kills the echoes
the prince the echoes at the beginning
but kills them when it exits the quiet
echo block
yes or even after some time i'm thinking
that after a given echo started
it will be quieted in quotes because
it's some sort of standard notion of
quieting after some time
actually another useful one would be
another useful one would be
um that you have a maximum fixed number
of messages
like echo messages on screen much like
the general stop message
well but you wanted to to just delete it
from the back instead of delete it from
the front like general stop
right so it's like it's like if i have
some program and it's printing logs
i want it to delete the older logs yeah
right stop
printing new ones
so so yes it is a good idea um
well okay so let's just look at what
this
so the thing christopher that i was i
was
i was playing with this idea of a
temporary block
or echo temporary block or something
which
which when it goes out of scope the
temporaries that have been printed
inside it disappear
sure but so how would that what would be
the
the functional mechanism for this print
up to some another echo so this would be
essentially
an echo temporary block with a uh
yeah this would have some kind of
logging length arrow whatever it is
well that's operations yeah i mean
one question is if this is the right you
know whether these should be one
function
yeah i'm not sure that these should be
because that's a different thing so it's
it's a basically
um this then the other one would be echo
uh you know echo limited log or
something
you know and then that would be
uh um
i think it's limit echo right you're
limiting the number of echoes
right so what are you saying you're
saying it's limited like quiet echo
it will be limited echo well the only
thing is i
well limit echo might look a little bit
like
you know the function limit yes
right well okay but i mean the semantics
here
the two cases that are of interest are
you have a window of echoes that are
that are being used but then then of
course there's a question of whether
you know if you have nested limited
echoes
um um
uh yeah ben on our live stream is asking
whether
whether my statement that echo is
popular is more than anecdotal
and the answer is i don't believe so
right now
i mean we have had various projects in
fact even wolfram language data records
the number of uses
of um we have corpus corpora
of warfarin language code and so we know
in terms of of code that people
um you know that's in the function
repository or in our internal
uh uh systems and so on we know
frequencies of functions use it function
usage to that we do not know it for
interactive use
um echo is probably not in those corpora
very much yeah that's right relative
temperatures interactively
right yeah um i
i do see many people using echo what i
don't know is whether it is because of
the
return the the the expression or because
the type setting is
nicer to identify them
i mean i use it for both i mean because
it's just i mean
probably mostly i use it over print
because it
it returns but i also just use it in
general because it just seems
like the more modern version of print
right
but okay let's come back to this
question i mean by the way the thing we
were discussing
um discussing this general side effect
function we were also discussing the
the monitoring framework um right so
this is very
relevant to the monitoring framework
because i mean
so so for the case and i guess for for
all these cases with echo but
but i think especially for the case
where it deletes from the back
right if you're deleting from the back
it sort of implies you don't really care
about the messages in general you just
want to be able to see them for the
purpose of monitoring
so it probably is very common that that
you want to delete from the back
and you want it to delete all the echoes
once it's done
yes just in terms of the question of
whether there should be one function or
two
yes yeah i mean basically
it's you know it's basically a proof of
life type of thing
of is the function doing anything or
it's just sitting there
i mean it's the easiest way to report
progress is to echo something
right i do like this idea of a limited
number of echoes being
being um because i can imagine that
being and also with a little bit of
extra control
see what happens if things are being
echoed too fast
and you're beginning to i mean can we
deal with that
in other words let's say that there's a
burst of echoes
10 000 echoes that will be coming
through really really fast
where and if it was an echo window
so to speak um the um
uh if it was sort of a windowed echo
with not the right term again but but
um uh would we um
uh we haven't had the deal you're gonna
ask if if basically if it will get
destroyed
by having you know a million echoes go
through it well no i'm saying that
probably in the front end
we can simply not even bother to try and
display the things to the screen
but it's going through too fast i mean
you know we just have a minimum time of
you know i don't know some number of
milliseconds
and just even don't even bother to push
it out there if it's right
in that time window yeah i mean i guess
first of all we haven't had to deal with
this issue because normally you know the
issue of having too many echoes on
screen
kills you first right before the
frequency of echoes
but i mean right i think this is in
general good because i mean
maybe well except it still requires all
that
math link traffic i mean i
does it i i think you'd have to be super
careful and
wait wait why does it require math link
traffic because because at source
on the kernel side it's going to know
there are too many echoes being
generated
and then it doesn't send them that's my
point avoid that traffic
okay i mean maybe it could do some sort
of right but
i guess but then how would it know what
to delete
maybe you could just maybe just the
colonel could could could mean i mean
i i don't know how echoes work right now
really i mean it's just math link stuff
but
maybe you know the colonel could just
maintain a list of
of the echoes that should be on screen
and then every you know
just every n seconds it will just push
that to the front end
yeah it makes sense i mean in other
words that the colonel maintains
the the echo window but i mean i think
well it doesn't but yeah but it doesn't
no
it doesn't know it doesn't have the cell
object until it's
communicated with the front end right so
i mean it would i don't know well
now we're getting into weeds of details
of implementation that i don't know when
we need john or somebody to comment
but right i mean right now the way it
works
is it uh uh right it didn't
it uh um
right basically you print it
you get a cell object back and the front
end knows to delete it
at you know at certain conditions
right right so if you're if you're
replacing
the ones there i don't see how you do
that okay so here's a here's a case
that's kind of awkward
let's say we've got windowed echo but
then we've got a nested call to windowed
echo
okay we've got a logging length of four
or something
so we've got two windowed echoes from
the outermost window echo call
and then you know one from an inner one
and then two from the outer one and it'd
be a little bit weird what's it gonna
look like on the screen
as it i mean it's going to it's going to
be kind of interesting looking
it's going to be things are going to be
flowing in in different places
so can you ask me of time remaining
which you can nest
time remaining and time constraints with
temp remaining and it will just take the
longest
i mean i guess or take the shortest
right
yes i'm going to which is the right
condition here but
i guess it's a maximum or minimum
condition well
you're saying then that there's that
whenever you have a windowed thing it
just says
let this be the total number of echoes
on the screen
rather than the sub tree the evaluation
subtree of this
defines the number of that goes up to
this point
okay let's let's just maybe another way
of
doing it i mean so maybe another way of
doing it
i i don't know much about the whole
monitoring framework thing you're
probably just talking about
but um maybe there's some way of
integrating with that where basically
so somehow you get it so that the echoes
will appear inside of that sort of
dynamic blue box
and so then there's you know it removes
a lot of the weird ambiguity because
it seems like the problem is that echoes
have this kind of weird
very global scope because they're just
printing in the you know
in the notebook but then you know you
can have these complicated
scopes of of of these you know echo
limiting functions and echo windows or
whatever
but but maybe you know the thing to do
is to use this box here because this box
is sort of like a already is dealing
with those
right when it has multiple things here
clearly by being a box
if there are no sub boxes within the box
so presumably if there are multiple
functions that are being monitored
presumably the successive monitorings
come out underneath each other is that
correct
that is correct which is probably just
fine i mean i've seen multiple
monitorings happening
it's just fine it's kind of like a stack
trace you know the things that
it extrudes down and then it comes back
up again
and i don't think it's terribly weird
and i don't think there's any need for
it to be a sub
right i mean so the case is one of these
boxes
within that box there is another thing
that needs to be monitored i don't think
it's at all weird
when the thing being monitored comes up
underneath yeah i mean i think that's
the standard thing i mean even like
i remember like i don't know windows xp
installers i don't know if they still do
this you know they would have the
the slow progress bar on the top and
then the fast one below it
yeah i think yeah a bunch of mo yes yeah
the visual studio installer certainly
still does that
okay all right so fine so that's a fine
approach so then what christopher is
effectively suggesting
is that one of the possible
progress you know the one of the
possible with progress
types of things you could do is throw
out an echo
so what we were discussing previously
was how does a function like map
throw itself out there with its internal
variable
to be monitored with the progress
monitor we don't know the answer to that
but what's being said here is right now
the way this progress works so the it
seems like in this example
here the only thing you can do is this
dynamically scoped what is this doing is
this
how how did earth does the scoping work
well it it's um
i mean it is it is it is right it is
it is a fake right it's a fake scoping
construct right it's held
it you know is it dynamic or is it like
and it's it's it's dynamic
okay okay
so what's being said here is the
alternative to this would be
in this with progress thing
let's see is i mean so for example one
could imagine a situation
in which it is a um
uh
you say something like with progress
and that defines the outer block
and then you say um
echo progress for example
and then you give something to echo here
and then the with progress
that's in a semicolon there that just
says with progress that
and with progress then says you know max
echoes or something
goes to four and then that becomes just
a box
that contains the results of the echo
progresses in it
so maybe one one other kind of
even simpler way of doing it could we
not just have
i mean because it seems like there's a
general problem which is you know
if you just without any rapper print a
billion echoes that you know basically
crashes your front end
um so i mean maybe there should just be
a dollar max
echoes and then you know if you want to
restrict it for this particular
computation you use block
yeah but i think that's going to be
uh i think it would be probably good to
have a dollar max echoes in general just
because it's
it's you know i mean we already have the
maximum output size or whatever
and that you know makes you feel all
safe until you start using what is
that what is that what is the thing what
is it called dollar output size limit
output okay
but that does not affect echoes
presumably
correct correct which is the dangerous
thing
right but there it's also not right but
also so
the dangerous thing is that it's not so
much the size of the echoes but the
the quantity or the rate of echoes
probably although i think it is also the
size sometimes because uh
like if you're echoing really big stuff
you know if you're echoing you know
uh does that cost like 10 000 output
size limit
uh no because that's that's not in the
main loop
right oh but i mean if you actually that
i'm not sure this is the question you're
asking but there's an interesting
question which is if you run echo of
and then something that's too big i mean
you can try it with that documentation
example
the question is does it does it uh echo
that
box that says the output was too big or
does it right that's what i'm asking
yeah that's what i'm asking by the way
the documentation i think is out of date
but
it outputs the whole list okay
right because the output size limit is
is
part of the main loop right do
so we could automatically iconize if it
goes beyond some limit
yes i mean in other words we need an
analog output size limit
for print for example
i'm surprised that hasn't come up by the
way devon can you make a note of the
fact that that example needs to be
updated
why does it need to be updated isn't
that hard to date isn't that the wrong
is it
just oh try running okay well well
but let's not bother updating it well
you need to set the limit first
to some um
yeah okay right but we're about to
change the box again anyway so there's
no point in updating it now
one okay okay
but but again i mean there are two
things then that echo needs it needs
you know to respect maximum output size
or something like that
but i think the the one that i run into
much much much more often
is having too many echoes on screen
where you accidentally print 10 million
echoes
right okay but that that's a
look the fact is okay
the general stop mechanism which is a
third of a century old
right we have thought about modernizing
that
it's not obviously broken right now
and so that that is a stop from the end
as opposed to
a window the results
so what you're suggesting i think
christopher is
a stop from the end version for echo in
addition to the windowing a certain
number of echo
results i mean there's there's two cases
here
right i mean yeah right i understand i
mean maybe i
i think that the thing is echoes are
fundamentally different from messages
in that with messages you know
you want to know the first thing you do
yeah you want the first message that's
where it first went wrong but for
echoes when you're logging you just care
about the current statuses
exactly that sorry for interrupting you
but that that's exactly what i was going
to say
okay all right but so what you're saying
is that an optimal case
of an of a number of echoes limit
would be to to what are you saying the
number of echoes to have on the screen
at the same time or are you saying a
stop from the end
mechanism because i mean the stop from
there
yeah no i i think it should stop from
the beginning
because again like like italian are just
saying you know you care about the last
echo right but what about the case where
you're burning all of your cpu time
generating echo messages
right i mean i i ideally it would still
stop from the beginning but you're right
maybe it will maybe it will kill you if
you
uh right so i think there are different
cases limiting that goes one thing is
the rate of echoes coming out
another is you know stop
you know stop generating the echoes
and another is window the echoes
you know only some number on the screen
those are the cases that i can see
uh i mean on that rate
limit where do we have things like that
i mean that that
that's something that would have been
very useful a bunch of times with
printing and things
be able to have a rapper that says
i mean what does it do i mean i mean we
sort of have that with
once right you can you can limit it to
right once has a second argument of how
how how one time it is and which i think
can be time based
roman wrote it so he should be able to
answer this question
um so you can use it as rate
limiting but no you cannot it's got a
persistence location
uh okay maybe that was the old design
before we
um oh no oh there's existence time
yeah we have several
options controlling rates so if you do
question mark asterisk create asterisk
sorry what um do question mark asterisk
evaluation rate limit that's for cloud
objects
refresh rate is for um
dynamics yes
so echo rate is max echo rate basically
but again what should it do should it
cue up the message like
should it delete okay so you you
understand right i mean should delete
the messages that it doesn't have time
to do should cue them up
what you know maybe and then print a
little ellipses that says that there was
stuff here that got deleted
yes or it could even just print an
ellipsis print an ellipsis with a
counter
yeah so sort of like the output whatever
it's called output size limit where it
says this many
bytes were you know right this many
echoes were skipped
this many echoes were skipped well right
the counter could just be counting up
but that's not going to take up extra
screen real estate and and clearly
in i mean that's more after you stop
right
you could you could have a soft stop
where there's an ellipsis there
it just tells you how many have been
omitted
and then what does it do does it print
one message every
uh well i think i wasn't addressing the
eight i was not addressing the rate case
i was addressing
this was a better thing for talking
about stopping the echoes
i think this is i mean i think um
that so in other words it's it's not a a
dead stop now in terms of the echo rate
well i mean what i would think is if
there's a window of echoes
it updates the window only at a certain
rate
so it's like it maintains the the state
information in the kernel of what should
be in the window
and every rate echo maximum echo rate
seconds it pushes
its version of what that window should
look like out
right you keep talking about some window
i mean are you literally meaning that
all of the echoes will be collected in a
single cell
well i think christopher's proposal was
to have them be in the progress monitor
i'm not sure that's a good idea though i
think it's probably better if they're in
their own cells
okay like they currently are
um and and then you need to keep track
of which
cell objects are out there and which to
delete and what to replace them with
ethan is commenting on a live stream
that would be nice to have a mechanism
for
for auto collapsing repeated echoes
i mean i know though i often have
repeated echoes
for uh i mean at least by default i
don't think i'd want that because i
i often use repeated echoes just to be
like hello
and it just means that it's running the
next loop
right yeah one thing we don't have but i
you know we just don't need it is um
you know we've got echo timing we don't
have echo with a time stamp but we don't
need it
okay let's let's zoom out for a second
to what what we're talking about here so
the issue is
this started off with an echo temporary
idea
right and the two branches were going
down
either it is a cell and it gets deleted
or possibly it is in a
in a progress box and it goes away when
the progress box goes away
i think the advantage of a progress box
is it's pretty well defined if we have
the nested echoes issue
that that issue goes away if you use
progress boxes
um if there is a window of a small
number of echoes i think a progress box
is pretty reasonable
because the idea of having cells that
keep on getting deleted and so on you
know like i said experience yesterday
actually
i was using zoom and some
talk i was giving and for some reason i
was a co-host of the zoom
and um the uh people kept on
entering the meeting or requesting to
enter the meeting and that kept on
causing me to lose mouse focus so in
other words
kept on putting something up at the top
of the screen and i was trying to type
and i can imagine a situation here we
have to be quite careful with that
that nothing well i i worry about
putting a bunch of
cells on the screen maybe that's wrong
wrong i think that's the other direction
because i think that having some funky
dynamic
object that's trying to display text i
mean
this is one of the advantages of echoes
and prints versus dynamics is that
echoes and prints are like very reliable
in that there's no weird dynamic stuff
it doesn't matter if dynamic updating is
enabled it doesn't matter if it's on the
screen or off the screen or anything
like that
it will print unlike dynamic which i
think is much more fiddly in this
way yes no i agree okay there's another
point which is the sort of proof of life
display okay which is an and
donald on our live stream comments on
this but but
you know even something which is like
the the dot
cycling around dot dot cycling around
is useful we don't have a mechanism for
that right now
in other words to know like a weight
cursor when you run an evaluation
the or when you run something yes i mean
that i mean i mean that
that that you have a particular function
okay so so
back the very first computer i used a
very long time ago had a tone generator
and you could tell what it was doing
because it would make various kinds of
strange noises um in our current
situation
right you're inside some complicated
function
you'd like to somehow know that
that nail it's a complicated thing but
that function is the one that's running
go ahead well i i was basically just
going to say i think that's hopeless
uh i i'm not sure what that is short of
you know you calling about you know you
introducing some variable and
using evaluate with progress no i'm
saying the following thing
this is a okay so so here's what i mean
um uh you know the is it
alive wrapper um
and basically during the evaluation of
exper
what is displayed is some kind of or or
um
uh you know show liveness
um during the evaluation of expert
something is displayed on the screen
that shows that that evaluation is
taking place honestly
that's pretty much equivalent the only
difference is
that's kind of equivalent it's like
putting an animated
uh image on the screen echoing an
animated image
while this is being temporarily echoing
an animated image
while expert is being evaluated
is this not basically uh you know
dynamic of
last of stack or dynamic of stack would
be better
it's something like that except that
except that it it
affirmatively establishes that something
is going on there
by showing um you know by showing some
animation type thing but you don't know
i mean
the thing is okay so one option is that
the stack is changing like if you do
dynamic of stack right
one option is that the stack is changing
and you know something is going on
another option is that it's inside of
some big kernel function
that's just sitting there and the stack
isn't changing
in which case this is a live function
has no hope of knowing if something is
going on either
and you know you can put a little
animation on the screen but that
animation
doesn't know anything
is this going to do anything useful
oops it was a very silly thing to do i
think you need to make it a bit slower
and maybe make it a bit more complicated
yeah
i think you need the this is in reverse
order
k28 and j2k
how many bugs can i have in this one
piece of code
um no i don't i've got the actual table
do you have two tables yeah so sorry
sorry i thought it was a single table
okay this stack is not showing anything
that dynamic of stack is not working
right maybe try monitor
i think i've done this before i thought
this worked i thought this worked too
maybe again try maybe using monitor
and what around the table
monitor of what become a stack or
dynamic stack
really okay i mean i don't know maybe
that makes no difference i'm just i'm
just it's sort of weird because it's in
a different cell or it's a different
computation or something
no no he's confused
by the way monitor is a good example of
something which does what we're talking
about here
that is a scoped display so to speak
and by the way we should probably uh
restyle monitor so that its output
like echo has some annotation to it
what do people think of that
[Music]
it's not essential i mean what's
happening right now is not particularly
bad
so right now i think if you did have
something like that it would be nice if
there was an option to at least remove
it because
yeah right and then couldn't you just i
can't
put whatever you want inside the monitor
here so i'm i'm removing that suggestion
but this is a good example of something
i mean the only problem with monitor is
that you can't monitor things like
uh like map
right right but in terms of your keep
alive
function right you can right right that
would be just dot
dot right yeah okay so what you're
saying is
that what i could do here is i could
just say in this
ellipsis or
yes sorry what what is the point of this
function i mean what
in what case will it will it
no it just shows you it exited that
piece of code you're quite right i i
just never thought of doing this and
probably would put that example
actually why don't we put the following
example okay here's a good question do
we have
curated animated images
uh i don't think we do right now
i don't think so but if i said yeah
so sorry just all you're saying is you
want a weight cursor
i want like there is what about what
about just putting
like progress indicator there or of you
know
appearance goes to indeterminate
okay let's see if this works
ah what did i do wrong oh they're not
images they're not images
i mean this is kind of humorously silly
but um
yeah that's kind of amusing that should
be given as an example i mean it's not
oh yeah
right well i think progress indicator
you know with uh
appearance goes to indeterminate or
something like that would be a
more slightly more professional yeah
a little less trying to look like a
command line
so right so you need to give it right
there's and i think it's appearance goes
to indeterminate
let me double check that um
yeah it's just the the modern mac
indeterminate ones are not very
or not what happened to this is stupid
this
this why isn't it showing above no i
think no because i don't think that's
what
it just has this very slight gradient
that moves across to the right
on the new one use progress indicator k
comma into the indeterminate
symbol
oh i see there is a little little oh my
god oh
oh i know yes the one i was thinking of
is is
is the string is the string
necklace so if you do progress indicator
and then appearance uh
goes to the string necklace
what are all these other like arc up and
stuff like that
yeah well maybe you have to get rid of
the k
indeterminate yeah
right and there's also a string ellipsis
that gives c and percolate
i think percolate is the one you you
want actually
try percolate there
okay that's like on the cloud
yeah that's pretty nice i mean the
maybe this would be incredibly annoying
but there's an argument to be made
that uh well i was gonna say there's an
argument to be made that it's just have
something like that by default
because i do know there are a lot of
like beginner people get confused
because they don't know when things are
running because they don't know to look
on the right-hand side
but at the same time i think it'll be
kind of annoying if every time you run
something it prints a cell because then
that means if you're running many cells
everything is going to be moving around
yes that's a different issue of whether
that is a different issue of whether we
should
show whether the thing that's i mean
you know the idea of showing i mean
that's something for the
user assistance meeting and probably
something that should be on the agenda
is this question of whether whether
there should be some activity shown
because
back in the day you know inversion you
know when we invented
thickening the cells those were invented
in 1987
when there was a limit to what we could
do and they went along with this absurd
weight cursor
that uh operated in the vertical retrace
interrupt
but i mean i think that the i think that
i don't know i mean i think that
the thick brackets are fine it's just
that a lot of you know beginner people
don't know that they need to look over
on the right
oh no i understand if the brackets in
any way moved
i think that would be that would help
so can we add that to the user
assistance meeting having some
sign of life in the evaluation brackets
right and in fact i think what would be
particularly useful is if there were
like a percolate
or you know some sort of animation there
for the
cell that's actually active so you would
know which of the 17
you know inputs you're running which
is the active one i should just say yes
well but yes right and if you if you're
the sort of person who only does one at
a time then you just associate it with
evaluation but if you do more than one
you'll quickly realize what it's doing
right so devon can you make sure that
goes in the user assistance
meeting yep yeah i'll pass it along okay
so as a comment here different
time domains user domain system time
idle time
yeah that's that's um
um yeah the whole question about
audio monitoring so actually ethan is
commenting
why add a new symbol with progress why
not just generalize monitor i agree we
should generalize monitor
um the
question and bizarre question of a beep
right i mean we could we could perfectly
well have a thing that says
what would happen if we just put a beep
here
is this gonna am i gonna regret this i
just beep
you might just beep
once okay
what is that and monitor isn't even
whole area i guess it has to be held at
all
yeah yeah but on the other hand if i did
this
i have to believe yeah
it'll beep every time k is re-evaluated
it did beep every time k is re-evaluated
look one other thing definitely we need
to have is something in the monitor
um because i hadn't thought of this idea
of having
um and we might want to make this
simpler we might want to just have a
second argument to monitor
that is a string that will generate
those kinds of uh
you know proof of life type things well
but the thing is i don't know i'm i i
think
is a little dangerous because monitor i
mean pretty much any two expressions
in monitor is a valid monitor
so i i think you know i should just say
yeah i mean even if you just had
one argument that then it takes options
if you have one argument form of monitor
but then there are options you can't
distinguish that from
normal monitor i understand
although we can we might just want to
carve out
you can't have an option structure there
being the thing that is displayed as the
monitor
um yeah
let's see
so boy ethan is suggesting
what we really want is a highlighter for
running input cells where the currently
evaluating head is indicated
yeah yeah we have that actually we've
had that forever and ever right in the
debugger
but nobody ever uses it
i don't think it's i don't think it's
realistic i mean i think that the
the concept of you know having little
thing that runs around
it's like the turing machine head that
runs around on your expression showing
you what's evaluating i
i just think it's i mean it's
interesting i suppose
i mean okay question can we do that is
there any
any hope of being able to do that
with with brenton's code tools stuff
there is some hope of being able to do
that
okay actually devin add that to the next
brenton code tools discussion
i mean i i think it's probably hopeless
but um
um uh
yeah i mean the right i mean the
debugger
you know has various known issues but
nobody ever uses it so we
haven't invested the resources to really
upgrade it
and i think the the the fact that the
debugger has to be picked
um you know you have to say up front i
want to debug this it's just
it just is a complete killer so nobody
trusts the debugger at least i don't
to not do something crazy because as you
say it hasn't been
um right it's in this vicious cycle that
yes it has some known issues so people
don't use it
and then because people don't use it we
haven't invested the resources to
address those issues and if you know
it would not be super easy to extract
the bits from it
it's impossible but look the code tools
project
is something which will eventually come
back and you know but what it's doing is
more a synchronous code
uh indication okay so look
let's let's come back to what we were
discussing here
so we've got a number of things related
to
kind of i think this is going to have to
have a separate meeting
we've got this echo limiting business
we've got
echo windowing and we've got the
relationship to progress monitoring
the first summary
okay so so maybe you guys can think
about this and see whether we can come
up with a suggestion
um
possibly reusing monitor possibly not
uh i think it is clear
that a
delimited echo temporary makes the most
sense where if the thing gets back to
the rebel top level
it removes the echo temporaries but
where there's the possibility of
removing them at a lower level
if that made sense right so that way a
particular function
could say oh yeah i'm evaluating and
then as soon as the function is done
it's like it doesn't tell you anything
anymore right so it's a lightweight form
of the progress monitoring stuff
it just says you know the typical echo
might just say
um
uh well what would it be you're not
suggesting this for system functions
right
you're suggesting this for user code i'm
suggesting for user code yes
uh donald is suggesting text to speech
for these things i have a feeling
that that would be monumentally annoying
i mean
[Laughter]
you know there's an option in the
accessibility uh
settings for mac where you can ask it to
to read the dialogues or at least there
used to be back when they really had
dialogues now they have their
notifications set up
and i used to have that on because uh
it was it was useful for for the one
purpose of uh when uh
when it would complain there was low
battery it would like make a noise
otherwise it was incredibly annoying and
eventually i turned it off once they
started
adding notifications for like email and
messages and all these things because it
just
it was just it's crazy
right but you can certainly get that by
putting speak in there
um let's
stay running once though i guess you
could say speak of k
and then watch uh i don't even know what
happens if you run speak
like a million times before it's had a
chance to finish
it it does some weird stuff i mean it is
not our responsibility we already put
the stuff in a buffer
it's it's being fed to the system
speaking buffer
right which is the the right which is
quite different from doing speech
synthesize and then
you know audio play or whatever it is
that you do to actually hear
an audio right i mean this would be a
different thing that would actually get
um right so this is the more dangerous
way to do it
well this takes a lot more effort i mean
we're not just using
the i mean this this would actually have
you know we we actually have the full
um the full story um
uh the comment from perkinj
a web hook to the evaluation of a
function
you know we were looking at web hooks a
couple of years ago and we've never
implemented web hooks to my knowledge
this is the wrong group people really to
talk
to about it we just never really got
you know worthwhile enough use cases
i mean clearly you can say in
in any of these things you could you
could um
uh
let's see
just by the way stephen i'm going to
have to run in a couple of minutes
so we've gone over time here um oh boy
we i can't believe that we didn't get
through what i
i thought we would get through these
okay so this is this is being re
look we need a summit meeting anyway
about um the progress monitor stuff
okay um we'll set something up okay
and and let's let's let's talk about
this temporary echoing
in connection with that um and and
summarize what we already got to here
okay let's just look at redirecting echo
oh boy yeah and what has happened to
this logging thing
we already talked about that right
having a function that is just a logging
function
yes uh so joel was working on that okay
fine but so there's this question
right of what should we do
is there an echo action that will
essentially redirect the echoes
right maybe i mean
i don't know i think this this relates
to the other stuff about echo scoping
and stuff like that
a bit i mean may uh well
and i started thinking like maybe one
way of thinking about echo is it's like
throw right and right now
uh it's like thrown and right now
there's no catch and so it's just
printing to the front end
but you know but you could have a catch
which has some other behavior
right i mean right i i'm surely
echo respects print action
right uh because it's
ultimately calling print is it not
i would think so right and and so i'm
not sure why we need
these other things
which actually it's not even clear to me
if those would be kernel or front
options i mean print action is a
front-end
option right it's a option on the
front-end or a current notebook etc
okay is that something that needs to be
checked and we don't seem to have
information here whether print action
affects echo
i mean you could try just doing it here
but i guess it doesn't
probably because it doesn't does print
action affect cell print
or only print
oh and maybe it's using
cell print um i guess it would because
it needs that little orange thing
yeah okay all right so that's a separate
thing to look at hey
one thing i also wanted to raise with
all these progress dialogues
one of the things that i think they do
is in a terminal front end
they do spray themselves out as
text is that not correct it i can you
confirm that
i'm sorry can you repeat the question
okay so
these these monitor things here
progress monitors if you run them in a
terminal front end
do they correctly turn themselves into
ascii
yes now exactly how well they do that
depends on the capabilities of your
terminal
uh but yes okay but for example let me
give you another case
if you use um remote job submit
and you submit something to aws batch
for example
that thing has a has a
job log we should know what this does in
the job log i mean in other words it
can't use the the the
term cap you know whatever it is you
know curses library to start deleting
characters in the ascii display right in
in the job log it will just do whatever
i don't know how they work but i i
assume
just every character that's put in there
ends up in the log
probably although i have to imagine i
mean there are a lot of
things people run that have little
command line you know progress
indicators and maybe they have something
where it you know it deals with those
like it might just show the final state
of the progress indicator like it might
allow you to backspace and stuff
yeah possibly okay fair enough and not
just give a whole giant thing or maybe
just
maybe it puts the control h's into the
file and then whatever is rendered is
rendered
no it will detect whether you have
something
right so for a dumb for a dumb file it
will just
you know for dumb terminal slash pipe it
will just
uh you know print successive lines
so you'll you'll have a long
whole bunch of you know progress bars
that are um
[Music]
so if you do uh you know
if you evaluate this and will from
script that's
piped to uh you know the cat or
something you'll you'll just see a bunch
of
uh of uh of you know ever longer
progress bars
right all right i think we need to wrap
up here
um and uh
oh boy these these uh always a lot of
complicated things to do here
um um
ethan is asking are there any machine
learning or visualization
meetings for the next version coming up
soon i'm sure there will be
um i'm i'm uh yeah
expect them i don't know exactly when um
uh
all right i think this this is as far as
we can get today
um uh i would like to just comment that
that they're a bunch of more ambitious
language design core language design
things that
that whole combinator adventure has
raised
do with evaluation orders causal graphs
the possibility of turning trace into
something which is a trace graph
those kinds of things which i think we
should address at some point i
assume this is the correct meeting
series to do that probably
not sure um i would say most of those
things are more lcc-ish
fine okay but i mean i i think they're
going to be they're somewhat heavy
lifting i mean basically the idea
is can we insert and it's not completely
unrelated to this whole progress
monitoring thing
in other words for example for trace you
know
long and orphaned function um you know
is there a way of making a trace graph
that is actually meaningful and uh
and if so what that is doing i mean it's
somewhere in between
debugging monitoring whatever else it's
a it's an
indicator for example one thing that
we've learned
is this notion of causal graphs of you
know
where did the output from this go what
did it affect
right so in fact as i realized to
generate the causal graph
for the execution i mean you know we
have an execution graph which is what
trace graph should be
if we could add a causal graph on top of
that execution graph
that would be quite interesting because
it would allow you to see at least in
some cases where you know this two that
i got where did it come from
so i'm sorry i really have to go okay
i'll catch you later
okay see ya okay happy holidays
everybody
i think we should wrap it up um the
folks on the live stream will uh
see you uh another time